On Wednesday, Russia's
President, Vladimir Putin, claimed
that Ukraine
was planning
to use a so-called dirty bomb.
A claim that his underlings
have been peddling for days.
The accusations were roundly denounced
by Ukraine and its Western allies.
They say this rhetoric is nothing more
than a Russian attempt
to ratchet up tensions and escalate
the conflict.
So how far will Putin go to turn
the tide of a war
that has not gone his way?
Joining me now is Boris Bonder,
who spent 20 years as a Russian official.
He was a diplomat
based at the United Nations
in Geneva before
resigning in May over the war in Ukraine.
He is one of the highest level officials
to publicly defect over the war.
And he joins us now from Switzerland.
Welcome, Boris.
I want to start by asking you to describe
why you think
Russia's decision making and decision
making apparatus
got to the point it did
in the invasion of Ukraine,
because you have this
fascinating foreign affairs essay
where you lay out really how Russia
has evolved
as a kind of ruling elite in Russia,
has got narrower,
more and more insulated, more and more
kind of divorced from the outside world.
What do you think?
You know,
what happened
that got us to where we are?
First of all, it did the the result
or outcome
of this evolution of the Russian state
which we had
witnessed for the last 20 years
and even longer,
it has been
getting more
and more isolated from society
And this is very dangerous
because people
who work in the government,
they get this misinformation
from their colleagues
and they make their decision based
on this miscalculation
and misinformation.
And we see it as a result of it.
We see it as in the
the invasion in Ukraine
in the kind of decision making structure
you're describing.
Boris, I assume
bad news does not travel up the chain
in other words,
people are not likely to
to tell Putin, Mr.
President, the war is going badly.
The idea of trying to take Kiev was bad
all that kind of thing
probably doesn't go up
the chain as much as one would hope
it would.
I believe it is very close to truth
and I also believe that
when you report some information
high to the high command
to you
and the leadership of the country,
you have I mean, in Russia today,
you have to make it
as pleasant as as possible.
And of course,
you don't want to displease
or upset your bosses
and the government itself
because it would
it would
jeopardize your career prospects.
So
when we hear this talk about a dirty bomb
forced by
Putin's aides, Lavrov now Putin himself,
what do you think is going on inside
Is is is this.
Are they feeling a certain pressure and
coming up with new, new threats?
I think that today
Russian leadership is actually at a loss.
They're trying to adjust themselves,
accommodate themselves.
To this new reality.
And the reality
says that Russia may well lose this war.
And, you know, it's
it looks quite chaotic.
Really,
because there is no strategy under this.
That is only some kind of random ways
of looking for some opportunities
to get themselves out of this very,
very,
very peculiar, very dangerous situation.
What about the threat of a nuclear weapon
being used in your career as a diplomat?
Have you ever
heard of the Russian top leadership
talking about the possible
use of a tactical nuclear weapon
Do you think Putin is bluffing
or is this real?
I don't think that
these nuclear nuclear weapons
threats are very real for now.
And I think that they will not be real.
If Putin gets the very clear
signal from international community
that any use of nuclear weapons
will have the most grave consequences
for Russia and for him personally.
And what about negotiations?
So imagine what you described
as if Putin feels like he's losing
and that that fear continues.
That fear continues.
He could end up
using a tactical nuclear weapon.
What if the battlefield ends up
in a stalemate?
Let's say the Ukrainians stake
more territory.
Carson, maybe Kharkiv,
but then it bogs down at that point.
Could you imagine
Putin being willing to arrive
at some kind
of negotiated settlement,
which would be a compromise for everyone?
All the parties have
absolutely different and
antagonizing
priorities and
goals in these negotiations.
So for now,
I don't see any prospects
for any real negotiation.
So if if what you say is true
and we are in
for just a long, protracted war,
what happens inside
Russia is just Putin's hold on Russia
so strong that even a long war, even
maybe more mobilization
would not weaken it at first.
I don't think that Putin is really ready
for a long, protracted war.
I think that his strength,
his regime is a little bit
overestimated now.
And now we see in Russia that
there is a lot of confusion
in the context
of mobilization for instance,
and there is some kind of unrest
and the discontent within the population.
So I believe that Ukraine may or
may not go on this
path of long, protracted war,
but they are capable.
Ukrainian army is capable of defeating
Russian troops
and of liberating their own flags.
But for that, they need the continued
and intends
to seek assistance
and support from the West But with that,
I believe they can win this war
in quite short terms,
maybe in a few months.
So because they have already shown
very significant progress.
Boris.
Fascinating insights.
We really appreciate you coming on.
Very, very useful.